hello and welcome to a special edition
of ec canada live nerd alert style we're
doing it my friends we're taking over
for a live discussion about the moon
night finale with some of our favorite
fandom gentlemen jordan calhoun hot off
the release of his book piccolo is black
and coming to us from ranch and jeff j
managing producer at bleacher report and
host at bet x coming to us from not a
ranch uh jordan and jeff good to see you
guys how are you
thanks for having us
great man great good to see you
all right so it's a big week for marvel
fans the moon night finale is here and
we'll get into that in a hot minute but
it's also doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness week which is very
exciting you can hit up uh my sort of
review preview of the first 20 minutes
of the film right here on our youtube
page okay back to moon night however we
picked up right where we left off this
time with mark making the choice to go
back and save stephen
looking pretty rough man
i don't know if you can hear me
from the moment you arrived
way back then
we were so young
you saved me
i survived because i knew i wasn't alone
you're always there
alive full of hope and i tried to
protect that and i failed
i couldn't protect you
it didn't abandon me you didn't abandon
me
and all of it all that feel back there
was looking there
it's looking pretty good
there's no way now i'm gonna abandon you
you
[Music]
are the only real superpower
[Applause]
i ever had
all right so as much of the show is
about like a big world threat it's more
about the relationship between
mark and stephen and guys how do you
feel about the show in his final episode
uh how it's resolved that and what it
looks like moving forward did you think
this was the best part of the show uh
jordan
absolutely for me i think i mentioned
this two weeks ago we talked about
episode four about how stephen and mark
and their relationship and their
cohesion and their character arc would
be if they stick the landing on that the
most important thing of the show and i
think that's what held true in that
scene and ultimately in them deciding to
come together like that was
the most interesting and compelling
thing to me on top of what hero was
doing on top of the threats of the world
and everything else so i'm glad that
they brought the focus there in the
finale because the rest of the finale to
me sort of
fell by the wayside in terms of where my
interest was
yeah jeff after the big revelations of
episode four and five and diving deep
into the history of of mark and stephen
how do you feel you know they brought
everything around in the final episode
i think they wrapped it up pretty solid
i mean you still had the threat of ahmed
that you had to solve but even bigger
you had this relationship between marcus
even that also had to be resolved you
saw character growth within one person
and outside of the given everything that
was happening outside the world which i
thought you know was the best part of
the show because i don't think that they
wasted any beats with any of the
characters or any of the themes in the
show but to say i don't think it's a bad
thing to say that marcus steven's
relationship was the best part because
oscar isaac went full like super saiyan
god with with his acting like the acting
in this show was probably the best that
i've seen in
any show this year just after isaac if
he's not up for awards this year it's
it's a crime the fact that
he wasn't
two different people on screen like you
could make the argument that people
could think yo does he have a twin
is he triplets of the way he's able to
switch and even you know we'll talk
about it you saw three characters even
if you didn't realize it
this was this was what was most
compelling to me and i think the way
that they ended it even with the way
that the uh cliffhanger came into play
yeah
it had me wondering whether i was real
in the world right now this was kind of
like that
thing there was a part of me that like
wanted to see even more about just this
character and these characters way more
so than the big world threatening thing
that we got that we kind of always have
to have in shows and movies like this
and you touched on the thing i want to
talk about next there was that tension
of like is there a third and who is the
third and we finally got our first look
at jake lockley finally confirmed in the
post-credits scene look at this
i beg your pardon
[Applause]
is
then
[Music]
[Music]
can't you
you can't hurt us
yeah
you want to know something
mark spector truly believed that after
he and i parted ways i wanted his wife
to be my avatar why would i ever need
anybody else
when he has no idea how troubled he
truly is
meet my friend
jake lockley
[Music]
wait
[Music]
so i'm a big fan of that reveal and
obviously fans have been waiting a long
time to see jake lockley appear in the
show uh but the question i have is why
introduce him now because as far as we
know there's no season two of moon
knight in the works at marvel aside from
the twitter slip up of like deleted
series for season when both the moon
knight account and the marvel account
were promoting the finale but with a new
blade coming up with mercel alley dave
whitman's black knight about to grab the
ebony blade and eternals a werewolf by
night special starring gail garcia
bernal a daredevil reboot i mean there's
so much uh after spider-man no way home
and of course doctor strange dividing
excuse me diving head first into
multiverse i say there's definitely room
for moon knight to return to the screen
is very dark phase four so given all of
that and all those possibilities is
there uh a way that you would love to
see
moon knight return with like jake
lockley included uh jeff
yeah uh you know first off uh carlos i
would say that i don't think dick
lockley was revealed in this episode i
think he's been revealed throughout the
series you just got the confirmation in
episode six and uh you know i i i love
an ornery uh brooklyn accented murderer
who has no moral compass in my and my
vigilante so that's cool um
how i would like him to be reintroduced
i've had a marvel night's agenda going
for a while
and and we're one step closer blade you
mentioned it blade is on his way dr
strange he has a lot going on this week
but dr strange is still there
um there's another character who serves
a god that carries out vengeance too
and he happens to be daredevil
so i i think there's there's a fantastic
way that they can bring him in but the
beauty of moon knight now is that he
serves both the people level community
level
and the the fantastical supernatural so
you could fit him into any type of role
depending on what the threat is and what
the storyline is and he'd fit seamlessly
but i think for now
if we're getting into the weird
supernatural dark my marvel knights
agenda to have to bring the band back
together ghost riders somewhere down the
way and we go after mephisto who
everybody's been wanting and thinking
that he was around every corner
this is the team to go after him
i love i know i am petitioning for ghost
rider to come back too
jordan we had talked previously about
how like
is the show gonna stick the landing with
these characters and also the fact that
there's no way that they would just
abandon this and that this would be a
one-off and done how would you like to
see uh moon knight come back
i'm glad that jeff mentioned daredevil
it would be great to see a gritty sort
of daredevil adjacent version of moon
night where you see a lot more of him
being brutal you see a lot more of him
in action scenes it was sort of correct
what i think is one of the major gripes
that a lot of people have with the first
season is that you don't really see as
much moon knight as fans might have
wanted to see you'd also be able to see
more jake being that sort of grimy
violent vigilante hero so that's what
the fans want i think what marvel is
doing right now by not announcing a
second season is seeing if there's
enough of a fan fever pitch to want to
bring new moon knight back so that they
can have this you know celebratory
moment among fans when we do get the
version of moon knight that we want to
see when he's being grimy when he's
beating the hell out of everyone when
he's having sort of these these
moral dilemmas on on what it is that
he's doing i think that's what everyone
is going to want to see and i think that
the shortcoming
of this season sort of the asset and the
shortcoming is that they ambitiously try
to do
10 to 12 episodes worth of storytelling
in six episodes this really was a longer
story that if it was a 10 episode season
or 12 episode season like a daredevil it
would have been just to be completely
honest significantly better it needed to
be longer but they condensed it which
was an ambitious thing to do they fit a
lot in there but that leaves fans
wanting a whole lot more that we could
potentially get in the second season i
was surprised at the length of this
episode i thought for sure it was going
to be a longer almost movie length uh
affair so the speed at which they kind
of wrapped everything up surprised me i
will say i do like the move that they
made to make this season all about you
know this character because it's a lot
for fans to unpack like you want to
devote the time to tell everybody who
this person is before you let the
superhero parts really happen before you
see like you guys have been talking
about that street level violence and and
for me like all fight choreography that
i want to see that i didn't really get
in this series you know with moonlight
so far now
it should be mentioned that we not only
got mark and stephen as their moon
knight alters but layla also found her
powers in her fight to bring consu back
to save mark's life layla joined forces
with towerette to give us another
egyptian superhero
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i like that layla gets her shine in this
episode you kind of you know from the
moment you meet her that there is
potential for something very very cool
with her and her character and we got
that in this episode what do you guys
think about the whole uh the whole
joining up with tara jordan
oh i'm so glad tauret was the character
who sort of stole the show once she was
introduced she was an instant fan
favorite i love seeing her everyone
loves seeing her and to be able to see
layla get her shine by combining with
that character that's absolutely amazing
that was
the best that would that of what could
have happened in such a narrow time
frame
jeff what about you what do you think
yeah i i agree and i like that they
introduce the concept that
regular humans can be avatar to these
gods which
may not be gods in the sense that we
think they could be otherworld aliens
kind of like thor and and the whole
asgardian in the in the nine realms or
ten realms depending on if they're
introducing the tenth row eventually um
i i love it i think that a lot of this
source material needed to be updated for
current times
if you go and you and my guys my guys
over at uh super tuesday recap uh
they'll tell you that they you go on the
marvel unlimited and you look at like
more night source material they have to
put up like a warning like hey this was
written at a different time you might
see stuff that might be a little racist
a little of you know outside of what the
norms are today but they still you know
presented so that you can see where
they've gone and i think this is like an
interpolation of the scarlet skyrim that
they had before and i think every type
of update that marvel has made to this
point has has been beneficial to the
characters so anytime you get a new
character it worked and i think it
worked here especially for layla who was
resisted to conscious but so look which
can you blame him right casual flavors
of all the gods to be the avatar kanchu
would not be my first second or third
option right but she finally allowed
tyrette to to combine with her and she
got a pretty cool costume and great
powers on it so i think that just helps
to build the the roster of newer
characters or previously unknown obscure
characters in the marvel um in the
marvel roster and introduce it to uh a
whole generation of fans yeah i agree
with all that and also like how is she
the only person that had the sense to be
like maybe maybe not maybe don't make a
deal can't you or maybe try i don't know
well she got to be fair she wasn't dying
to be fair she wasn't doing anything
if i'm in mark's position and i'm like
you know god i apologize but this is the
god right now that's telling me you can
bring me back let me make the deal
dollar worried about it later
we got a comment here from kelly who
says such a great series would have
loved for it to be longer hopefully
they'll be longer next season with the
additions jeff mentioned now again like
we don't know if we're gonna get more as
far as like a series goes but moon
knight is definitely coming back so
aside from some moon night mysteries
this episode fans were really hoping for
a marvel style ultimate showdown
and boy did we get one
i'm really jazzed about showing you
these new skill sets we have all right
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah jordan was this showdown like a
satisfying
visceral finale in the mighty marvel
manner
no
so
my answer to that is no but i sort of
have to contextualize it
from
my
perception of what i wanted the series
to be from the beginning this big sort
of self-contained story the way that we
would have seen in other 10 episode
stories versus what moon knight actually
is which the way that i'm looking at it
now is that it's a six episode trailer
for what could potentially come if fans
absolutely love this six episode trailer
so if i'm looking at it in
what moon night is in this shortened
version of the story to introduce this
character then yes it was satisfying it
was fun it was basically what i wanted
to see a lot more of in the previous
characters but if i'm looking at it in
the context of what i thought or
expected coming into the series then no
it was just a snippet that i would have
wanted to see a whole lot more of
yeah and like we talked about a while
back you know with the marketing
materials and the way that this thing
was being presented to us this is a
character study this is a character
study but you know i think you can't
really get away from i don't know if you
can't it's hard i think to get away from
sort of the style of finale that we got
given what we know about the mcu jeff
what are your thoughts on that on the
finale the fight scenes and how that all
wrapped up
yeah i think it was a natural
progression of what we saw like think
about it if you went from
going having this battle within mark
spector's own mind and the journey that
he went this was more like you said this
was more of an introspective
character driven show which let's be
honest these a lot of these marvel um
disney plus shows have given you
something different like i i've
appointed um
uh phase four to being the individual
comic series like like infinity war was
like the major event now you're getting
world building within everybody's corner
of the marvel cinematic universe and
here you got somebody who has been doing
what he's been doing for a while you saw
that room full of all the all of his
victims right which whether or not they
deserved it that's for conscious and his
other gods to decide but
you see somebody who is building to this
point and even with what we got in the
finale we did get the culmination of the
story that we saw you got two different
versions of moon knight fighting two
different styles along with layla and
scarlet scarab with the avatars fighting
each other which was kind of like the
representation of the fight that was
going on below and you got mark
seemingly being released from his
contract which kantu hasn't been like
the worst 360 deal you could ever
imagine even to the point where at the
end we wonder
whether or not we're in his mind he's in
our mind and what's really going on
which how i'm interpreting it is
he's now trapped the way each other was
trapped throughout the series and jake
is out which is a problem for everybody
so i didn't expect a whole cinematic
clash i expected what i saw was them
trying to stop arrow from um
fully releasing homage so i was
satisfied with it i think it was
ambitious to condense it in six episodes
but if you ask me do i want to be left
wanting more or wishing they trimmed
down i i'd rather be left wanting more
i will say i you know
you just described everything that
happened which is a lot and i feel like
it was a lot to try and cram into the
time frame that we had plus ads that i
guess like the satisfaction that people
might expect from all these different
fight scenes now this episode had two of
my favorite action movie things ever a
big kaiju battle which we had
with the gods and then like that street
level like when mr knight comes out with
the filipino martial arts and does that
one sequence that we saw loved it that
is legitimately my favorite part of the
actual episode because like
details wise i like that stuff but i
could do without some of the things that
they i kind of i think they kind of lean
on now
like um a giant monster fight like i
don't necessarily need to see a giant
monster fight and everything and i
really don't want to see any more like
people fighting while they're falling
out of a thing or while they're falling
like and they're having a fight scene
and then there's gravity like like give
me something else give me something else
next time okay
so now that we've broken down all the
easter eggs and uh details from the
finale i want to see what you guys
thought about the series as a whole so
we're gonna keep this quick jeff j your
thoughts on moon night in 30 seconds
um moon knight is an ambitious series
and this was an ambush to even bring out
this character um from what i know about
the character and what i expected they
pretty much met and in some place
exceeded my uh expectations i love
thrillers i love suspense and i love
anything to do with with the mind and
having you having you to think and i
think this is something that was
different than what we've seen in
previous uh marvel uh mcu installments i
think they're differentiating a lot
they're giving a lot of people shine and
i'm i'm left wanting more which is what
i wanted and i'm glad people got to see
this character um on on a bigger stage
so the possibilities are endless and i'm
i'm ready for more
jordan the question before uh when we
did our sort of mid-season thing was did
it stick the landing for you what are
your thoughts
yes moon knight stuck the landing for me
but not in a way that i expected i
expected it to stick the landing in a
way that in isolation as a series we
would be able to look back as oh this
was an amazing like one of the best
marvel series from a character that i
wasn't expecting to love so much and now
we have this big sort of full compelling
story it did not do that that also
wasn't its goal i'm coming to realize
where it did stick the landing was
making people now like jeff alluded to
care about a character and be bought
into a character to want more of him in
the future if that was the goal of moon
knight was to have us bought into a
character that most people had never
heard of before had never thought much
of before then it did stick the landing
in being a successful introduction to
that character so i think yes it stuck
the landing just not in the way that i
expected when i wanted a full longer
more cohesive story the story wasn't
cohesive there are still loose there's
still things that we want to see bear
fruit in the future but now to their
credit
we all want to see what happens
you know for me i i really did enjoy a
lot of the series um and for
for all that it does differently from
everything that we've seen in the mcu
thus far uh
thematically uh story-wise and and the
things that they dive into the real
world things that they dive into for me
it kind of in a way was the most
traditional mcu
story we're taking a character that
people don't really know about that
maybe don't even really care about
putting some heat on this character
making this character someone important
someone who is uh who has gone through
their own personal struggles and needs
redemption and then now we're going to
put them out into the world of mcu and
see what they can do and that way for me
i feel like it was kind of like the
quintessential marvel cinematic universe
property guys
i want the rating
on a rating of like
sliver of a moon to full moon full moon
being the best
what is moon night where does it sit
jeff
um i will give it a third phase
i think that's the one where it's like
it's not a full eclipse it's like the
the it's probably what you see like the
moon knight symbol right yeah i'll give
it that because i had i had like
expectations that it was going to be
good um kind of what jordan said there
were areas i didn't expect it to be uh
the psychological thriller that it was
going to be and you know dealing with
things such as like dissociative
identity disorder and things like that
you have to tread a certain line you
know of taste and just interest and all
of that and i think they did it in ways
i didn't think that they were going to
do you know like it's one of those
things where i've said that comic book
stories are some of the best stories i
put comic book stories up there with
shakespeare and all of the classics
because this is what really defined
creativity and and all of that and i
think it gets maligned too much and when
you have these stories at the forefront
you can tell them in compelling ways and
i think a lot of people uh discredit and
disregard them just because they're
quote unquote children's tales and when
you lose that children's mentality for
ambition and creativity then you lose
your chance to grow as a human so i
think they're showing you that they can
tell these stories and these characters
in a variety of genres in a variety of
different ways so that's why i'll give
it the moon knight symbol will go we'll
go uh third phase of the movie
jordan i see a lot of nodding are you
are you a third phase do you believe
that as well
absolutely couldn't have said it better
than jeff said at three quarters of a
moon for me as well i think they
ambitiously tackled a lot of themes that
were unexpected for me they tackled you
know the mental health stuff that you
would expect from mark spector but also
some generational trauma they uh
the abuse from his parents how they
coped with it i think the dad got off a
little bit too easy but that's another
conversation for another day
that i didn't expect and then there were
the reason i wouldn't give it to the
full moon is because there were some
some shortcomings there were things that
i expected that i didn't get especially
more fights more action more things like
that and also they had a very limited
runway to tell a long story so that you
know that's obviously going to be
ambitious for them to try to do it but
it's almost impossible to land that
really really well so really well in
terms of getting us to
his character and alarm and getting a
broader audience face to character a
little bit shy of amazing given the
limited runway that they have and the
things that they couldn't fit in
yeah yeah gentlemen
thank you so much for joining us you
know i think the big word the big
takeaway for me here is ambition the
ambition to do the story the way that
they did and like to be able to treat
all those sensitive topics the way that
they did i think was really fantastic so
anyways thank you so much for all your
thoughts you guys are geniuses love
having you love chatting with you now
everyone else remember that i'll be back
in our regular time slot live today at 2
p.m uh so in the words of steven grant
laters gators